did you get a prenup when you got
married no and I you did it I'll explain
to you guys why so I think and I talked
about this I I loved the prenup
conversation I think it's important I'll
just there's three reasons why I didn't
get a prenup but the first reason is I
actually believe prenups are good and
bad they're good because they protect
you they're bad because they don't
protect you enough what I personally
believe is something which I I did
research about this called a marriage
contract you may not like this but
please give this to me how many kids you
have three so let's say Ali married her
man and she said she wanted three kids
right she gets married she wants three
kids all of a sudden prior to the prior
to marriage he agrees he said she said
she said honey I want three kids is that
cool with juice of course baby you want
three kids we're gonna have three kids
she's married five years into it hey
when are we having our kid uh next year
when are we having our kid on next year
it's year eight he's like I don't want
any kids anymore
should she stay in that marriage
she he agreed and she had both agreed
that we're gonna have three kids that's
why she married him he when then when it
was time to have kids he changed his
mind well I don't wanna I don't want
kids anymore should she stay in that
marriage let's go on the guy's side
because the red pill guys love when guys
are being the victim so you're a man and
in your marriage you you agreed that
we're gonna have sex let's say twice a
week that's that's an agreement I'm just
saying we that's a verbal country we're
agreeing that we we're good at least at
least twice a week all of a sudden she's
like I'm not in the mood anymore
she's like oh now now I'm gonna be all
of a sudden that'd be almost immediate
but go ahead okay and then and then
months into it right yeah she she says
well I like I only want to have sex once
every once every six months should he
stay there you both agreed initially
like yo we're gonna do this consistently
and now he's getting it so he stay there
so to me what's very important about the
marriage is that you before you get into
it both of you guys need to agree upon
everything this is this is where I think
the Nuance in the in the evolution agree
on everything so the woman is protected
as well as the man is protected and so
to me that's what me and my wife did
before we got married we talked about
everything so every single scenario
every single thing me I'm not a money
guy I'm not I'm not motivated by money
so therefore the money like I'm
Different everyone knows me I'm not a
money guy so you can have all the money
I have my brain I can start from Ground
Zero I'll build the money back up I
don't mind money but to me because it's
another argument that we can talk about
later is that the kids is a whole
different conversation kids kids are
more wealth than money so I was more
obsessed with children than money
because end of the day like I said we're
gonna talk about that later but so to me
I in regards to losing money I don't
care about losing money take whatever
you want if worst case scenario things
happen but by having a marriage
agreement both of you guys understand
what's expected of you and if one person
obviously breaks this agreement both
families know so if if I if she wants a
certain amount of kids and I say I don't
want it anymore then her family knows
though yo Hafiz you promised my daughter
this you didn't give it to her so it
makes sense that this marriage is no it
is is this we all understand what a
prenup is all right like it's signed
lawyer day bing bing bing bing bing what
is a marriage contract is it a written
agreement it can be you're saying that
the families know each other what is
that it can be it can be one of three
things right it can be written between
you and this individual which is the
least ideal the second ideal is you can
you can actually get a mediator or a
legal Arbiter to actually sign this for
you so therefore like in in worst case
scenario if you go to court this is now
a legal document right so this is a
legal document that can be able to be
proved in court but you know I know a
lot of the red pill guys don't like the
idea of marriage being controlled by the
state and if you look at a lot of
traditional Eastern societies marriage
is really agreement between families so
to me I think it's really about the
families agreeing to this and the
families being aware of expectations on
both sides so therefore there's family
accountability because what's problem in
the west is there's no accountability
like you say if the wife dude we we
agree mostly on all of these things you
understand what's going on here when
you're talking about these marriages and
business contracts and family this is
where we agree and unfortunately we get
into the loss into the romance and the
feelings part of it which feelings do
change right your feelings change about
me about a minute ago people changing
thus life changes right thus though the
marriage comp track doesn't change with
the state so you have to have those
things understood and be in the process
just okay so let me just paint a picture
here so I was married very briefly okay
divorced divorced uh-oh but I had a
prenup yeah yeah but the the entire
without you know throwing myself under
the bus here
she needed to expedite the marriage you
know what I'm saying in order to yeah I
got it so I said I got you baby I love
you but you know we're gonna you're up
to sign and date here and these are the
expectations I've had if I do this for
you and it wasn't like a marriage built
to last it was a you know I'm here for a
good time not a long time type of
situation you could read between the
lines here if you know what I'm saying
okay but we're still cool shout out to
you Lauren if you're watching all good
um but better believe that I had a
prenup in that situation so that's when
I was in my early 30s now I'm in my
early 40s life's even better you know
money's good career is good still in
shape still still what you would call
sexual market value Peak all right shout
out to Rolo basically did a whole
calculation I'm in the 0.13 percent of
men I'm like okay my ego's pretty big
already boom now I just got an inflated
Eagle thanks for all the pump so Life's
good but I had a conversation with a
girl recently who's uh what I would say
uh
a very high value woman let's put it
that way okay and we're saying all right
if we ended up ever together
I would want a prenup no no no no I'm
not I'm not I'm not down for a prenup
was what she says I said well I'm glad
we're having this conversation right now
before this thing gets off the ground a
little bit she's like no and she made
some very valid points as to why she
wouldn't want to sign a prenup and I'm
like well granted I hear you and
emotional and and all that kind of you
know like I love what you said about
east and west and I said yeah I just
now I'm gonna need the prenup baby girl
like sorry like no matter whatever
happens so
I'm trying to understand like the prenup
the marriage contract at the end of the
day you'd be a fool as a successful guy
to not establish some type of boundaries
some type of protection to say hey look
I hear you you want to have this Fantasy
Land Cinderella Snow White Vibe go down
right Beauty and the Beast thing but
like mayor what first marriage is almost
50 don't work second marriage is that 60
something 63 third marriage is 75 so
like the more and more you get married
you realize all right this whole thing
so I'm understanding the balance between
the emotional component because you're
gonna have to have hey I love you I want
to be with you forever or else I
wouldn't get married yeah but just flip
a coin while this bad boy is going to
work out or not at the same time I hear
what a fees is saying is like everything
can't be so robotic and so structured
that you can't have any feelings and
emotion so I'm trying to kind of grapple
this and I add something to this girl
see this is the thing that experience
offers that sometimes experience doesn't
so he talked about experience and you
know being open-minded to experiences
but a guy who has significant investment
experiences has bumped their head as
well yeah they wouldn't be called bitter
they would call be called experience
right but in this situation what people
don't know what's behind that curtain
when you go into court and the Love Is
Lost and also the agree the agreements
aren't being upheld with the marriage
contract are piranhas sharks they
typically come in the form of lawyers
judges and people in that industry who
make a lot of money with that being said
once you go on that room I'm one of the
only people that have been in those
rooms
it's a dark place we call it the belly
of the Beast and until you've been there
you really haven't experienced a
marriage now let me just say this you
mentioned
courtroom you haven't been to your
marriage let me let me let me explain
why let me explain why you mentioned the
50
63 yeah 70 but do you know that these
don't include the people who have
already talked to divorce attorneys see
many of those 50 there's an additional
percentage of people who haven't even
talked to a lawyer or I'm sorry that
have talked to a lawyer and they've gone
okay I'll stay baby
cheaper to keep her happy wife happy
life yeah I'll just accept what it is
I'll stay for the kids I don't want to
lose the house so it's more than 50 and
I'm saying tack on a couple extra
percentages we need to tack on at least
25 extra percent because there are some
people who have Revisited to have
visited it and many people reconciled so
it's bigger than that and when I add on
those percentages it adds some
perspective yeah oh [ __ ] there is more
than 50 these are 50 who legally got
divorced we're adding on the people who
said oh [ __ ] I've just gone what we call
thinking about it yeah man I think about
it or the person brought it up if you
don't do this I'm divorced so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
foreign
[Music]